thank you
[Music]
so some more cheating has been going on
because you're a cheater trying to get
his black belt you could cheat your way
to a black belt yep probably no don't
probably ask that smug
you know all the cheats out there maybe
I can't maybe I can't
so this happened in a poker tournament
um this is considered you know let me
just show you the video how about that
I'll have fun with a little bit of a
video she had one of those old-timey
things and like old westerns absolutely
old-timey things here we go oh what
happened her genies
all right Sashimi Sashimi that's amazing
bro
please
I'm looking away from the screen right
now why would you oh yeah her nipple was
falling out
so how's it cheating come on This is
distracting that's called an
old-fashioned nip slip
so yeah that's basically all I was not
cheating
is that we've got we've got a nip slip
are they gay she's not aware because
that's not cheating that's not cheating
dude that's yeah because it's like
that's wonderful wait it was it an
accident that's a free show
everybody how's that cheating what the
[ __ ] don't you think in like a five hour
game you kind of get desensitized after
like but also if they got cameras that
when they see her just [ __ ]
you know what I mean if she pulled it
out herself they're like hey you're
giving me a boner that's cheating yeah
yeah it's like I don't get it what rule
is she violating in though
so uh to the naked eye
um I guess technically nothing but it
was found out later it's a misdirection
oh is she wearing a pixelated t-shirt
t-shirt
makes you think you do things naked but
she's not I'm brilliant to that why were
they blurring out
um she was actually wearing a bodysuit
with fake breasts under her clothes oh
and fully intended on exposing them
during this live stream those were fake
those are fake that's even better Oz or
titties aren't really that nice yeah
that's the cheese she's cheating hey
those are fake titties those are
silicones yeah that's not real yeah
distracting me with silicon city is not
the same what's even was she even
killing it though uh I don't think she
actually won but she definitely won the
number one Talk of the Town yeah she
committed that much a [ __ ] lost yeah
but yeah uh the idea of like you know
you can't use big titties your titties
are small that's cheating yeah give me
those I would my weak ass mind would be
distracted for sure I would not be able
to get the same I'd be like damn this is
a [ __ ] nipple out man I'd be winning
that [ __ ]
yes I was a cheerleader yeah all you so
you see titties all the time you didn't
see it all the time right
[Laughter]
yeah that's a cheap trick yeah right
easy that's a [ __ ] funny ass trick
though that's good she really got
disqualified in some way or not uh yeah
wouldn't you wouldn't she let's see
let's see let's see cheating huh
they are the owners of the Hustler
Casino Live event have responded to this
quote unquote oh Hustler Casino that's a
Gardena baby but I think a lot of people
aren't too bothered by it that much um
actually this same event recently just
got a flag for having a vibrator cheat
Scandal where what no no don't think
that vibrator
um but apparently this other player was
wearing a ring and because it's live
streamed other people like audience
members are preview to seeing like the
different things that are on the table
so somebody else would like vibrate that
ring if uh that person had the best
cards on the table so that was an actual
cheese pretty gangster that's actually
really don't yeah and then fake tits and
then just a couple weeks later this uh
fake and that's all she could come up
with is a titty didn't even vibrate or
nothing yeah right didn't [ __ ]
rattles that's not cheating though
entertainment quality you know what I
mean because like people do do things to
distract or whatever like if a guy comes
in a costume and wearing a wild wild wig
like is that cheating no he's just
distract the Wild Wings
zany poker player I guess maybe that's
why she didn't feel it popping out
because it wasn't real anyway
yeah that could be that could be because
just a titty bib yeah it's practically
your shirt it sucks when you cheat and
you still lose that's what I'm saying
like she cheated and still [ __ ] lost
dude but what's the point she was just
trying to just drag Grand endorsement
after this or something though wait
would you would you guys be distracted
like if you if you're in an intense
[ __ ] I think it would be like I I
could see your titty for like one second
and that's it I'd be like let me look at
my cards one more time
[Laughter]
sure it's your turn you're like huh hold
up what time wait what are we doing are
you looking at my car oh yeah Go fish Go
fish Go fish I'm just looking at my
cards oh is that the river
sorry I don't know what's happening Oh
no
I got 21 baby as a card player I don't
think I would be I would be distracted
because you're just so in a competitive
mode yeah but if I was a if I was a
camera operator yeah I'd forget to
change angles I'm honestly
yeah if you're just hanging out there
yeah yeah distraction all day and
there's so many dudes with sunglasses on
like you can't even tell where their
eyeline is and they go like this their
eyes are bucking out
how much of a distraction could it be
like if you're playing poker like like
you're like you're looking at your car
yeah and there's like 100 G's what you
have in your hands so it's like not like
a teenager [ __ ] dude [ __ ] yeah the
next car like if I'm the dealer though
that should be the deal you're not
actually in the competition but you're
in the competition so you don't really
have anything to lose but you're just
like dealing you're like oh you should
play cards
you could probably take people's chips
when they're not looking they're like oh
I forgot my cards again because I was
staring at those titties was there ever
a time that something like that happened
to you and you got distracted
like a booby popped up has there been
any time in your life that you saw today
it just made you oh what oh yeah like
you just lose your memory
I don't think any boobies ever popped
out in front of me
like just like what like the most recent
one is when we all went to go eat at uh
Honda yeah and then they were leaving
the tatami room and then that one girl
walked out to put her shoes on and she
bent over her titty popped out okay oh I
remember and then you threw up
I just saw it and I was like
that's oh yeah that's right that's a nip
slip right there
actually
this is Florida I was on stage in
Florida uh and there was a throuple that
was getting down while I was while I was
in the middle of a joke I'm like what
the [ __ ] yeah what was the what was the
race they were ugly
like you would throw them on ugly oh
what was the uh um it was no it was a
black lady a white lady she got one cup
a black lady a white lady and a white
dude
but it was distracting to be like oh
what the [ __ ] yeah and I wanted to say
something but I was like I'm not gonna
make them the [ __ ] stars tonight yeah
you know I [ __ ] them they don't get this
[ __ ] that's probably what they're
fishing for anyway yeah they wanted me
to be like at us we're special because
why would they do it wrong they were
sitting like right you know like they
were sitting pretty close to that comedy
show though yeah the comedy that's what
I'm saying they wanted they wanted me to
say something yeah they just love each
other you guys what would you have said
get our room what would I said I don't
know what I've said like I mean
can I join I don't know like I don't
know what the [ __ ] yeah you guys are
ugly even though they're ugly that's the
ugliest
like [ __ ]
you know they probably good kissers yeah
sure
they're not good in bed yeah yeah I'm
sure you mean that [ __ ] why are you
laughing I'm enjoying it you're enjoying
it yeah
don't you think maybe to have less
practice
or more I think you got me on that one
because they're ugly because they're
ugly they don't get
or like if you know some dudes like man
you know I need to work on my kitchen
I'm not I'm not that tight yet let me
get this ugly ugly oh vice versa over
girls you know because you want to be
fair you want to be fair and there's an
ugly dude there's this hot girl she's
like damn I ain't working my kissing yet
like let me get on this [ __ ]
right now I'm pretty sure y'all been
y'all been some practices before
I've been a practice round for sure the
the I do one time I'm like I'm like the
intro black dude for some for some white
girls
and they start with me and then they go
all right like black men one-on-one type
yeah yeah they start with me and then
they go all right I'm ready I'm ready
I'm ready you know what he's he's
halfway there he listens to Oasis yeah
yeah he's like halfway cheerleader I
think I could work with this bridge in
the Gap that is funny why you say Gap
we can't win in this room
[Laughter]
because he said right we got chicken
tenders we got gifts you guys are on my
[ __ ] list right now the first video
of the day I know
y'all starting off strong some of us
safe for now though do you want me to
come back you guys are next dude I think
I think Anthony Lee's gonna be next what
are you talking about dude I ain't got
nothing about grape soda in this video
that's the race
that's the most racist I've ever heard
yeah big fan but y'all haven't been like
the intro intro Asians to like
I feel like being Filipino you're more
like the intro to Mexicans
it's like a girl who's too scared to
date Mexicans I'm a chef Filipino first
oh you know what's funny that's what I
was gonna say you know you know the type
of girls that do not [ __ ] like me
what are the white girls that like black
guys really well because you're not what
they wanted yeah I'm far dang that sucks
they're like disappointed they're like
what what do they want like they want a
hood [ __ ] oh they don't want me
yeah that was DMX yeah yeah
oh that's like the girls that want
that's the girls that want the [ __ ]
anime boys and then they're like you
speak English and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
Is that real [ __ ] yeah they're like oh
they like I think it's all the weebie
girls though they have like an Asian
fetish yeah they want the K-pop boys and
[ __ ] and they're like you're just like a
[ __ ] you're just like an American Boy
really yeah the guys that do this yeah
yeah
and then they find out he's all good
girl [ __ ] hair anywhere you know
thank you
[Music]